>> Laura: COULD THIS BE THE
BREAKTHROUGH THAT TRUMP VOTERS
HAVE BEEN WANTING?
KEVIN McCARTHY INTRODUCED A
BILL EARLIER THIS WEEK THAT
WOULD            FUND
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S WALL ON THE
BORDER BUT IT HAS TO MOVE FAST.
IF THIS BILL PASSES, IT WOULD
HAVE TO GO    GO TO THE SENATE W
HAVE TO GO    GO TO THE SENATE T
HAVE TO GO    GO TO THE SENATE H
HAVE TO GO    GO TO THE SENATE 6
HAVE TO GO    GO TO THE SENATE 0
VOTES TO AVOID A FILIBUSTER
BEFORE JANUARY.
ALL RIGHT CONGRESSMAN
McCARTHY, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
IF THIS WERE TO PASS THE HOUSE,
AND THAT'S A BIG "IF," HOW DOES
THE SENATE HAVE ANY STOMACH OR
THE VOTES FOR THIS?
>> I DON'T THINK THE QUESTION IS
IF IT WILL PASS THE HOUSE, IT'S
BUILD THE WALL AND IT EVEN DOES
MORE.
CASE LAW WHICH WE PASSED, AND IT
KEEPS CHILDREN SAFE BECAUSE IT
REMOVES THE MS-13 GANG MEMBERS.
IT DENOUNCES THIS MOVEMENT
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS ILLEGALS TO
VOTE IN OUR ELECTION.
BUT I SAW WHAT McCONNELL SAID
TODAY, HE SAID WE WILL HAVE THE
BIGGEST FIGHT OVER THE WALL IN
DECEMBER.
WATCHING WHAT THE SENATE WAS
ABLE TO DO WITH KAVANAUGH, I
BELIEVE THIS GIVES HIM THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THE TIME TO GET
THIS DONE ONCE AND FOR ALL.
>> I KEEP THINKING, GIVEN HOW
GREAT IT WAS TO HAVE THE PARTY
UNIFIED FOR THE SUPREME COURT
SEAT, IF THE PARTY HAD BEEN
UNIFIED, AND THAT FIRST YEAR OF
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OF THE
ISSUE, WHICH WAS ONE OF HIS
SEMINAL ISSUES ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL.
AND I APPLAUD YOU FOR GETTING TO
THIS NOW BUT, THE STORY TODAY, I
THINK I JUST SAW TODAY IN
ARIZONA THAT A DETENTION
FACILITY THERE WAS SO FULL OF
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO STEAL
TREATMENT ACROSS THE BORDER,
THEY CAN'T SEPARATE FAMILIES.
IT'S SO FULL, THEY HAD TO DO A
MASS RELEASE.
HE DOESN'T WANT THE STUFF.
>> THAT IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT MAKES AMERICA THE
STRONGEST, IT BREAKS DOWN OUR
SOCIETY.
OUR COMMUNITIES WILL NOT BE SAFE
IF YOU CAN'T SECURE YOUR OWN
BORDERS.
THINK OF THE AMOUNT OF FENTANYL
OR HUMAN TRAFFICKING THAT COMES
ACROSS.
>> CONGRESSMAN, THEY DON'T CARE.
THEY CARE MORE ABOUT THEIR
LIBERAL SOCIAL CONDUCT BEING
FOISTED ON AMERICA.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE KIDS OR THE
RULE OF LAW, THEY DON'T CARE
ABOUT THAT.
IT'S ABOUT REDEFINING AMERICA,
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS ELECTION IS
ABOUT.
THIS IS THE ABILITY TO BUILD THE
WALL AND ENFORCE THE LAW, OR
HAVE NO BORDER WHATSOEVER.
WHAT THEY'VE DONE IN
SAN FRANCISCO TODAY ALLOWING
ILLEGALS TO VOTE IN OUR
ELECTION, POOR, THEY WANT TO
ELIMINATE I.C.E.
I WISH EVERY AMERICAN WOULD
SPEND ONE DAY WITH THE BORDER
PATROL AGENT.
WHEN I WAS IN EL PASO THIS WAS
THE FIRST PLACE OF THE BORDER
CONTROL BEGAN.
IF THEY SPENT ONE DAY WITH
THEM -- >> Laura: THIS IS WHY
WE HAVE FOX NEWS, THIS HORRIBLE
EXAMPLE OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
CRIME, A WOMAN IN NEW YORK.
NO COVERAGE OF THIS FOR THE MOST
PART IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA,
ZERO.
THEY CARE ABOUT WOMEN BUT WE
HAVE A WOMAN AT THE HANDS OF AN
ILLEGAL ALIEN AND IT'S JUST LIKE
IT NEVER EVEN HAPPENED.
CONGRESSMAN, WE HAVE TO GET YOU
TO REACT TO THIS EVER-INCREASING
MOB LIKE ATMOSPHERE AMONG A VERY
STRONG VERY ILLUSTRATED PARTY.
>> THE PEOPLE HERE THAT AND
THINK WHAT YOU ARE CALLING FOR
HIS PHYSICAL INTIMIDATION,
THINGS THAT PRAY THE SOCIAL
FABRIC.
>> THAT'S ABSOLUTELY UNTRUE.
IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO REDEFINE
PROTEST AND CALL IT SOMETHING
ELSE, THEY WILL TRY TO DO THAT.
WE ARE SHOUTING OUT, WE HAVE
SCIENCE, WE ARE SAYING WHAT WE
THINK, WE GET TO THE PUBLIC AND
WE ARE NOT SAYING THAT WE ARE
GOING TO KILL ANYBODY OR HIT
ANYBODY.
FOR WE ARE GOING TO CAUSE
ANYBODY ANY HARM, THAT'S A LIE
IN THE WAY THAT THEY ARE TRYING
TO REDEFINE PROTEST.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, WE ARE
OUT OF TIME BUT WHAT DOES THAT
ALL MEAN, GET IN YOUR FACE?
>> THAT MEANS IF THEY WERE TO
WIN THE MAJORITY SHE WOULD BE
THE CHAIR OF FINANCIAL SERVICES,
ONE WHO ASKS PEOPLE TO CAUSE
PROBLEMS TO OTHER INDIVIDUALS.
IT'S WHAT WE EXPECT OF OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS WHICH IS WHY